hello everyone I'm Alana this is Mike
Flanagan and Kate Siegel uh friends
where do people know you from who are
you what are you doing here what are we
doing here um I actually you probably
know me from elementary school drop-off
and preschool drop-off right now I am
mother of two children you may also have
remembered me from shows such as the
Ghost Whisperer and uh yeah Cold Case
yeah Rock City mob City this feels
intentional
I'm the writer director of Ouija origin
of Eagle very
very good
correct
about the loss of this episode five and
I'm very excited to talk to the two of
you because you're the first guest that
I've had on this like weekly talk show
thing I'm doing who have not played The
Last of Us I understand you know where
the story is going do both of you know
how it ends
I I do and I have I have played The Last
of Us oh sorry I didn't realize yeah
Mike has played I haven't played I
haven't ever watched anything about the
game so you don't know where it goes
nothing that's very exciting I know
where both games go and I'm just sitting
here being very quiet yeah I think we've
watched the show at the end of the pilot
I turned to Mike and I was like what is
it about or what what is it that would
be very hard that's got to be
interesting because I feel like watching
it with Rahul well like that happened in
the game every two minutes I'm like oh
you said the thing like I'd have a lot
of trouble shutting up uh what are your
impressions so far what do you think up
to like this is for all episodes thus
far thus far I I think it's it's an
incredible adaptation of a game and and
I think um it has hit Heights like the
third episode for me is such an
incredible achievement
uh just an in dramatic television much
less in in game adaptation
um but it's I think it's a remarkable
example of of how you can properly adapt
and
expand on yeah uh a a a a video game and
turn it into an incredible piece of
Television I think
the game itself is already a work of art
and so to transfer a work of art to a
different medium is is not
straightforward and I think they've
they've done as well as I've ever seen
yeah anyone do I mean I would say on its
own it's a standalone excellent piece of
work like I would watch it as
appointment TV if there was no game if
this was just it I'm finding myself
drawn to the characters and the
situation I think the cordyceps as a way
into the zombie story is super cool
genius but yeah but I know that that's
part of the game but like when that
happened I was like this is amazing what
a great way to explain it what a new way
to address it what a great way to like
design a monster because like having
fungus as a design element in a monster
is great
um yeah I love Joel as a character oh
the Valley's a character I'm really
really enjoying it this is also the
first episode where we got to see uh a
bloater I don't actually know if they
call them that in the show but in the
game the big tanky guy is a bloater
um did you guys expect that to happen
you know in episode four how we kind of
see those like looks of a sinkhole I
feel like everybody who played the game
is like that's probably gonna be a bloda
that's what we were expecting because
that was technically due in episode
three and it got mixed around do you
have any expectation for there being
some giant hulk of a thing popping out
of the ground okay we just need to
escalate the monsters to I'm assuming
there's a big bad coming there's there's
one called the Rat King yeah and I know
what a rat king is in real life so I can
only imagine
um I don't often see this escalation of
monsters it didn't take me out but it
was one of the first times that I felt
like oh right this is a video game thing
I have to beat the next thing and they
would have to make them harder like I
thought I don't know if the clickers are
supposed to be an escalation as well and
so it's supposed to be just like a
harder thing to beat all the time
whereas like for example in The Walking
Dead
the zombies don't get well they get they
get less effective yeah
zombified they are that eventually
they're just soup yeah so there's really
nothing exactly this is the opposite of
that so but I did make me aware that I
was watching a video game adaptation
yeah I think the bloaters do feel I mean
the bloated is your first boss fight in
the first game and I guess they do feel
like a boss fight in the show but I also
love like while I think that that is
potentially a little bit silly and it is
very video gamey the new thing there was
the introduction of the clicker um who
is I believe like a 10 year old
acrobatic she's a genius awesome yeah
and I was like oh that's so chillingly
creepy and how do you how do you make uh
this is the thing that I found really
interesting throughout the show in
general is how do you make zombies scary
to TV audiences who've seen zombies in a
million things and I think parts of that
is cordyceps the kiss was a choice that
was not in the game that's in the show
and that's something that like makes it
like a very like
this is a weird sexual horror thing
going on there where they overtake your
mind by kissing you and I think that's
like definitely a different barrier
that's how I work too yeah and that's
and that's where he is now
that's right that's true although I
wonder in the game in playing the game
was the bloater that easy to take down
you just like extra shoot it yeah okay
he throws stuff at you
um and that's the biggest difference is
they throw stuff at you and the clickers
operate a little bit differently in the
games too and that like not that
differently I suppose but they will kill
you the minute they touch you you're
absolutely dead you have to avoid them
pretty much at all costs yeah because
there is that thing right we can't like
the the zombies have to get close to
some characters but have to avoid other
characters for the sake of Storytelling
yeah and I I felt that a little bit in
this episode in that fight where I felt
like Oh weird that the zombies are
avoiding Melanie lynskey for example as
and like getting the people around her
that but she seemed to be able to walk
freely through that until you know yeah
no it was it was convenient
um it's interesting like the I think the
changes they've made so far
have been very smart and and kind of um
shrewd too like very very clever
one of the big things in the game that
you're not seeing anything of in in the
show is this concept of spores as
Airborne spores as a way to which is
realistic to how cordyceps works but you
know the the the idea of taking your
television characters and putting them
in gas masks for huge stretches of
important you know important chunks of
the show not not great and I think if
you're going to take that out you're
going to get some groans from the fan
base and and from just science nerds in
general who are going to say that's a
major way yeah fungus reproduces and and
spreads and you need to replace it with
something that knocks out the complaint
and I think that's why yeah
like it's like that just as you're
starting to go wait a second what about
this you see this thing and it's like oh
[__] yeah
why Rob the people of Pedro Pascal's
face even more you know right right does
he need to wear a mask again yeah just
bury him in yet another mask no it's a
secret way to act beautiful man yeah we
should be allowed to see his face
one checked into that loves masks
so he did say that he couldn't see
anything through the Mandalorian helmet
he's like I can't see [__] I think that
came out like a week ago that it's just
a tiny little sight line you can barely
see anything at all that's great yeah
Cove it's safe but you can't see uh so
the I feel like episode five and episode
four were really paired together as one
story obviously
um Kansas City we're seeing more about
Kathleen and her forces the first city
to overthrow fedra successfully
um how did you guys feel about the
Kathleen storyline and it's it's
presence in this like little mini two
episode Arc
it it's it's tough because anything that
follows the third episode is is
such a high point like yeah that episode
was so phenomenal that kind of there was
no way episode four wasn't gonna feel
anticlimactic compared to this complete
beautiful storyline they created in
three right so and how does the Kathleen
in the show compare to the Kathleen we
meet in the game are they similar in
tone attitude and personality doesn't
exist yeah it's an invention see that's
cool right I think what an interesting
choice that Craig made to make that's
super fun yeah it's very very fun from
like what we expect her to be it's um I
thought
more and you know
it's it's kind of any any zombie show is
going to fall into this to an extent but
this was where the show felt to me
familiar
having watched so much Walking Dead
yeah where it's and of course just I'm
not saying there's another way to get
through a storyline like this but this
to me felt like oh yeah this this
storyline of of the Rebellion that
overthrew you know over through the
establishment and is run by
someone who's uh whose agenda has been
over taken by this dehumanized kind of
like a like lady Negan yeah like uh she
reminded me more of the governor uh from
from those from those days of The
Walking Dead But it this to me was the
first time I was like oh yeah I feel
where the show is never going to
completely be able to step off of the
train tracks of what a zombie apocalypse
television show is yeah
whereas I think the game
the game has this sense of of not
walking on a on a path that's been yeah
kind of tried ahead of it my favorite
parts of the show would would I imagine
are the same favorite that you had
playing the game which is more like
exploring the world and like learning
the history and occasional almost like
zombie jump scare but I don't have as
much enjoyment in these interpersonal uh
who will rise and who will fall and the
rebels are really being violent and
we're trying to save this one group and
but we're just gonna pass through this
town anyway I'm not sure what we're
taking from this except that I think the
actors who played Henry and Sam were
fantastic yeah and I will remember them
I will remember Sam turning in the night
alone and how scared he must do that I
also I think I'm inclined to agree that
like I I
um
so far for me like I recognize that this
is like expert TV making and I keep
being like [__] do I know but Kathleen's
uh line has been the one that I've been
the least interested in the show so far
and you're right Mike that it could be
coming after episode three where we're
so invested it was hard to follow that
um but I I think it was definitely
interesting to get more insight into how
Kansas City was overtaken because we
don't get as much of that in the game we
do still have Sam and Henry uh Sam is a
little bit different this time around
because in the show he's deaf where he
isn't in the game and I really liked
that um yeah I think the the theme there
is a
you know it's two kids anyway we finally
actually see Ellie act like she's a
child for the first time and I feel like
the real theme of episode fives is very
much about innocence and what happens to
children and how we protect children and
I think that that's even echoed in you
know the the child clicker being the one
to take out Kathleen this is very much
like what does this mean for our future
and where does innocence live in this
world and it's obviously ripped from
Ellie again it was just it was just
heartbreaking even though the Kathleen
thread I didn't love I still feel like
the end of episode five hit me really
hard like in a way that I was like oh
[__] and I think that a lot of that is
um the performance from the actor who
played Henry I just feel like
like this moments in this round like
look at you get your CW acting out here
like that just like the HBO levels are
just they're so intense and raw and
emotional and like it's so brutal to
watch that like the at least reaction as
well
I think for all of the things that the
that uh maybe didn't have climax to me
throughout that episode the ending was
just it still had a massive gut punch
because those times
a version of it that focused more on the
children and the innocence and that
underground school yeah those are
interesting something that was there
like I I I know it not every episode can
be episode three and we can't have
bottle episodes every episode
but it would have been nice to have I
agree with you now the hearing you talk
about it it's very interesting and
correct point of view about innocence
yes you're very smart I appreciate that
thanks crazy oh I think you didn't
United I'll pay for that later is that
working for you on the internet it's
been great it's been really great yeah
thanks for asking but I wish that they
had had leaned in a bit more to that as
opposed to feeling like they had to have
big uh set pieces of lots of people
fighting an entire
storage units of people getting shot
and I get that that's the opposite of
the loss of Innocence but I think there
would maybe been
you know more to be done there but I
think you're right I think maybe that
made those tiny moments between Henry
and Sam
that much stronger and that much more
powerful and I just yeah I'm just really
enamored with the show I think a lot of
these things are also mirrors right of
like seeing how Sam and Henry all how
Henry treats Sam is still
on a journey of reflection for how Joel
should be treating Ellie because I feel
like he is still slowly edging towards
this fatherly role that actually kind of
comes in much sooner in the game I think
um so how do you how do you feel about
the way that their relationship is
developing around
what could go wrong
uh but yeah how are you feeling about it
oh I love that I want it to stretch as
long as possible I love a distant father
figure and I think Petro Pascal is a
genius and I think what he does so
clearly shows the Beating Heart at the
center of this man which is why Ellie
sticks around because I think if he was
outwardly fatherly to the way that she's
playing the character I think that Ellie
would have run I don't think Ellie could
have taken that much vulnerability or
intimacy or paternal energy I think this
is exactly the Joel that she needs
interesting take yeah I hadn't thought
about it that way Mike how about you how
do you feel about uh you know the the
pace at which they are developing the
relationship between those two
characters it's really the core of the
Universe I think that the pace makes
enormous sense given the trajectory of a
season of TV
um I thought it was pretty Pitch Perfect
in the game yeah very different very
different but but but for the you know
the
the experiential gameplay time that you
have there is going to be different you
know than than what's going to make it
into the into the show so I I
trust this creative team implicitly I
think it's giving the actors you know
it's it's meeting out kind of the uh the
arc over the course of the season in a
way that seems to be making sense for
the performances in a good way yeah I
think they're being well guided you know
it's it's uh
is it Eight Episodes or ten do we know
are we halfway through I think it's nine
we're over halfway let me double check
um
yeah I think it feels right it's you
know
I'm I'm
having an interesting experience because
so I've played the game but I haven't
played the entire game
um I've watched the entire game though
gotcha so you know the full story I know
the whole story I've seen all the cut
scenes
um and you know I've I've had the
experience of playing a good amount of
the first half of it
um but then I watched someone else play
and even watching someone else play the
game
is like watching the best I used to like
years ago I was saying it's the best
zombie movie I've ever seen I was
watching someone else play that game
totally yeah
um and and I know everything uh I I've
played part two
so you know I know a lot about where
this is ultimately going and you know
the big thing like a big thing I do well
because I like to watch TV
Community aspects
it and talk about yeah what's happening
each episode and so yeah I know yeah we
allowed to we can say the big thing we
can't say the big no I wouldn't have had
spoilers for every everyone else I've
had is talking about the game the whole
way though I haven't actually ever said
what the ending is so just avoid saying
what the end okay are you talking about
the big thing in part one or part two
she's talking about part two yeah the
beginning of part two okay yeah so I
think I think the part two one is a one
that I found very interesting to like
analyze this from the perspective of
like what do you change in a TV show for
this game that I agree is like very well
written and a very good movie really
yeah um but there are things that have
to change there are some things that I
think have to change because some of
them are too video gamey and thus a
little bit silly um like the first time
you shoot uploader really is really like
silly it's in a school it's a it's a
really cool scene but I think in a TV
show it's just gonna pull people out of
the tension whereas what I think they
did here was make sure while that did
show up and I do agree with you Kate
that it feels it does feel video gaming
not that that's a negative I [__]
love video games yeah it's definitely
you still lay it in a lot of tension I
think that whole point because you're
still seeing like from Joel's
perspective sniping up in in the tower
and you're watching Ellie um and
watching uh Sam and Henry obviously who
we're going to care about very quickly
so there's still a ton of tension um in
that but some of the things that I think
are interesting when it leads to changes
for the things that happen in part two
is I feel like they've made Ellie
preemptively a little bit harsher I
think she's a lot harsher than she is in
the game and I think that some of that
needs to sort of happen to make a TV
audience okay with certain things yeah
because it's a it's definitely a
different audience especially when by
virtue we're playing a video game you
have so much empathy for Ellie you are
protecting Ellie not Joel you're not
watching job do something you yourself
feel like you're responsible for her so
you have that connection straight away
you don't need to save the cat you have
this girl who needs your help to survive
and so you're like okay well I'm gonna
care about you so that connection
happened really quickly whereas again in
in the show it's slower she's a bit more
brutal I think Joel is also a lot colder
initially um which is like you said I
have so much faith in the creative team
too but it's going to take a little bit
of an awk for them to like get super
close the puns helped
yeah thank you I do think the casting
helps because I do think Joe Pascal
brings an just an organic warmth to
anything he does yeah when he's very
cold even when he is removed
yeah his likableness his love of of Life
shines through and so you see
what what this you know zombie
apocalypse has done to him as a person
and you just I care about them both very
much yeah I guess costing's the thing I
know very little about like with someone
like Joel in the costing process so when
you're auditioning somebody for that
kind of role and you want someone who is
a father figure
what kind of scene are you gonna try and
give them to make sure that you're
getting that that's a great question
because he still has to be hard and
yeah
it's interesting I I would give him
um
I would give him the breakfast scene
with his daughter and the pilot hmm
I would I would want to see him as warm
and relaxed and paternal as possible
uh and then I'd give him maybe the
introductory Ellie scene and see the
opposite so you don't you don't try to
hit The Sweet Spot you you do the you
can see both extremes you also he
probably didn't read
there's a certain amount
there's a certain amount you come to
expect from him because he's been able
to to convey
paternal protective warmth through a
chrome mask yeah that's true we know he
can do it
when you're not even seeing so like a
bowl on a stick or something like yeah
25 years of CV like he has so much
[Applause]
but I'm sure there were tests and I'm
sure there were yeah and and for the two
of them together I would have wanted
chemistry tests yeah for both of them
and um but yeah it you usually try to go
for something that's polar you go for
uh it's like if you want to you want to
see how far they push it in One
Direction how far they push it in the
other yeah so that you can confidently
know you can you can move back and forth
between them and find that whole
Spectrum yeah
because it's not a linear they're not
having a linear experience as actors
like they have to jump in and out of
whatever that Arc is
of their bond they don't film it
chronologically they're jumping in added
out at different points so you need them
to be able to I think it also depends on
whether or not Craig's wife is available
to play the part
[Laughter]
cell phone
very self-duck man
Securities for the whole world
uh yeah I guess you know we obviously
you'd be cast as Ally
obviously
so that that's how that's how I would I
would present it I think the Ellie's the
puppet yeah
[__] you I hate zombies I know but I'm
your dad that's really good Neil
truckman where are you at we have some
words for you I wanted to make sure we
got it up
uh the other question that that I think
you have really uniquely positioned to
ask is you spoke about episode three
being a highlight is that a thing that
you ever consider when it comes to
writing like in general if you're like
well we can't have this be too good too
early because then what how do we follow
it up I've never thought about that
before
yeah you know when you structure a
season you've got to be I I've a few
times had the fifth episode of my my my
shows have a very specific punch uh with
Hill House with Bly and with midnight
mass like episode five
was gonna land so hard
um and kind of recontextualize things
have a big emotional
punch that it was like Shoring that up
on either side of the episode was
important and for Hill House it was
tough because we had episode six coming
in after it which was one of the most
ambitious technical episodes of anything
I've ever done
yes but it starts with the one take was
that intentional yeah um yeah so it's
it's um
you know the you're very aware as you
look at the when you map out the whole
season
you know where those kind of tent poles
are that hold it up when it drops the
audience when you've injured them
emotionally and when they might need a
beat to recover
you know the the structure of that
season is is important you also
especially in the streaming day and age
this is some weird inside baseball for
you but
um the average person who's binging uh
anything watches two and a half episodes
so there's this pressure especially on a
streamer that HBO does this right I
think and when they they release weekly
it's been so nice but for streamers that
don't
there's a huge amount of pressure on the
third episode on what that's where
people typically bail
um even if they're just done for the
night so how do you keep them watching
and so what this struck me as was if
you're releasing weekly what an
incredible show of confidence in the
show
to hit that hard in episode three
um and what it told me as a viewer was
get ready
because
as hard as episode three hits the finale
has to hit harder yeah and they have to
know if they're putting out episode
three like that yeah they know they know
and yeah and so and it made me feel as
well it was so goddamn good it it kind
of it it immediately eclipsed so much
else that was happening in the show that
it I felt bad for episode four before I
watched it yeah sure it was just kind of
like did you we need a minute to kind of
all crawl out from under three together
the show doesn't have that luxury it
can't take the time it's got to keep you
but maybe that's why they went with
something that was a little bit
comforting that we kind of felt like I
know what show I'm in again a little
more familiar a little bit more familiar
and it's a kind of a smart move because
there was a lot of blowback on three
right like you know from people who are
maybe less
accepting and a nice way to put that
thank you
I've had a lot of fun on the internet
too
but like having something like four and
five to kind of get us back under feet
don't worry there will be bloaters don't
worry there will be uh zombies again
like we're not just doing this every
week maybe that was something of a
balance that's interesting yeah I think
there's also something interesting in
like like even if it's comforting it's
also a yank like of we deal with test
dying which I feel like should matter to
Joel a whole lot and then he's
immediately confronted with finding out
somebody else died for the person they
loved and both of these people are like
hey here's this task
keep going and I think that
um Frank's Leta oh Bill's letter says
something like do it for tests but
really in this context it translates you
do it for Ellie so he's immediately just
pulled straight into here's the next
thing keep going um and it's very rough
for Joel and that gives us that like
uncomfortable momentum at the same time
especially when it comes to Ellie
actually shooting somebody
does she yes she shoots them for the
first time as well and how he deals with
that as a dad and then oh my God whoever
that actor was that performed again damn
after he got shot when he was just
begging for his mom that just [__]
good they can't do that in video games
because then you wouldn't be willing to
continue that's one of the things that
you can like really amp up in the show
because we don't have to participate if
you did that in the game and be like I'm
not going to shoot anyone else like
that's horrible I'm not gonna do that
but it was really great and time and
time again were confronted with Joel
it's truly a cold-blooded killer yeah
and I think that's very important as
opposed to I thought
um I think the actress's name is Bella
who plays Ellie
um she in that moment where she believed
her blood was healing yeah I wondered if
she felt that or not that's a question
that I had that I think I might be alone
on I was like was she lying to him to
comfort him or did she think no I I was
under the impression and I think in
terms of character development it was in
a because she's been told she's so
special true right she's been told like
almost like a Jesus figure and a Healer
and she's the Gonna Save Humanity I
think it was very important for her
character development for her to come to
this realization that she's not like she
can't do it alone yeah you can't just
Heal the World by herself there needs to
be other people involved and I think
we'll see a more
um community-minded Ellie from that
point but she's pretty pretty selfish
previously she hasn't really listened to
a lot of Joel's instructions yeah that
that I hadn't even thought about it that
you're probably right that's like a
moment for her to realize that she can't
just do everything and obviously leaving
the note I'm sorry at the end
because she didn't fix it even though
she's been told she thought she had no
she wouldn't have gone to sleep yeah she
went to sleep because she thought he was
fine I see again because she fell asleep
on the chair I assume she fell asleep by
accident
uh I wasn't sure but you're probably
right my consensus seems to be the the
one that like most people didn't have my
takeaway was that I was like I don't
know she thought that it would work
because I thought it was very sweet if
she didn't think it would if she had had
the if she had had the gun in her hand
I might have I might have felt like she
She Was preparing she knew that she was
lying but I think she I I read it she
wasn't prepared yeah yeah
um but if she'd had the gun in her hand
then she's way more
calculator well yeah she's way she's
she's way more Daryl on The Walking Dead
than than a teenage girl yeah
um where's her motorcycle
any minute now uh I think there's also
like I'm not sure if I keep drawing
these parallels but I felt with the
Kathleen sort of subplot um part of it
could be that it's showing us
immediately after episode three in
alternate worlds right so like for these
these two episodes that are like I
really feel like four was just a bridge
for five it's a two-parter episode three
is what happens when two people just
become recluses and fall in love episode
five is what happens when somebody
instead of
um you know accepting the circumstances
goes full Revenge mode and it causes
pure chaos and where does Joel line up
in that like which one of these things
is he going to come to terms with where
his relationship with Ellie is concerned
or even where his relationship with Tess
is concerned and I feel like probably as
we get towards the end of the show we
might reflect a little bit differently
on how Kathleen handled things versus
how Joel might handle things uh in in
the show the series in my opinion really
is about love between two people family
whatever it's about love and and if it's
you know Kathleen did that because
somebody
died uh her brother I think it is
um then what would Joel do for somebody
being killed by federal being taken away
from fetchup well let me first you know
the show is about zombies Alana that's
not right there are also zombies who is
the [__] who put that up on did you
see that on the Twitter's purses no what
was this well I want to say it was like
Ben Shapiro or someone like that who who
attracts yeah it was like it's a zombie
show you know why are we wasting all
this time it was Ben Shapiro Rogue love
story when it's a zombie show and it's
like it's not a zombie I just like God
damn it I don't think it's a zombie show
at all yeah no no there's no such thing
as a zombie I agree they never are
[__] boring oh my God zombie sitcom
though where it is a zombie show where
it's about zombies like at home it's
called iZombie
um you can't tell him
that's like the whole thing I know he
said I texted him that you haven't
watched it at least twice a week
Ty led the effort into giving me a list
of the episodes I should watch but
they're all just gonna be episodes he's
in so you won't really get it just to
the show I thought it was in every
episode isn't he like it probably is
it'll be episodes he's good in
perfect so like maybe he's getting
dragged
and he's not he's uh he's doing ADR
right now I think the the thing is
though there is there's no such thing as
a zombie show because you can't make a
show about a zombie because a zombie is
is not interesting there's no Arc
there's no story yeah every zombie story
every zombie movie is about the people
every single one and like this whole
like it's a zombie show Get Off This
Love Story it's it's like that that
whole attitude makes me so angry just as
a horror fan yeah I mean like also as a
person but just kind of like yeah I
agree no none of these this is not a
zombie show The Walking Dead is not a
zombie show I mean if bench bear attacks
his way we all be watching Outer Banks I
don't even know if he's the one who said
it I think he was
take that
but yeah it's it's it it drives me nuts
when what I love about the show is its
commitment to telling the human story
yeah and and she does so beautiful it's
doing so well and like the oh the thing
that like roared out at me
was um the the opening of the of the
series which is that incredible uh kind
of
kind of TV show oh it was brilliant a TV
show no I didn't like it at first but I
think that the reason I didn't like it
was just because in my screenwriting
classes in University they told me that
I'm committing a sin if I open with a
talk show or a news broadcast and so I
was conditioned to go back
um but then I went back and rewatched it
and made sure that I removed that like
because a lot of stuff that you learn in
those classes is just someone who
doesn't have a job as a screenwriter
telling you how to do things then I went
back and rewatched and I was like you
know what it does set the tone
perfectly well it's like the same
argument as like you can't write in a
screenplay we see
like that's bad writing but used in the
right circumstances it's actually the
only thing you can do and this was a
quick way for I've never used voiceover
yeah I'll ever use voiceover that's a
huge one yeah but this is very much like
in all art forms know the rules so you
know when to break the rules right right
yeah D on the screenplay University sure
they would have so much fun giving you a
Dean you know I'm really good I don't
have to turn in my scripts for grading
uh you do to me except for through case
migrating has more to do with presence
and bribing the teacher
where were you when I was at the
Queensland University of Technology I
once got fired from being an s.a.t prep
teacher because I didn't take it
seriously enough literally the kids told
on me
[Music]
proud of letting those children down no
she was stopping them from having
pressure arbitrary depression no you did
the right thing it's not a big deal I'm
gonna teach you some tips and tricks
here but let's all try not to freak out
and literally I gotta call the next day
and they're like you don't have to go
back they don't think you're taking I
respect it a lot no I love it it's a
human story if there were zombies there
the same thing would have happened 100
yeah definitely stop setting for your
SATs
here we see Kate Stevo these zombies we
see the teacher deep uh as creatives the
both of you writing you know screenplay
as you are right now
um what are some things that you think
you can do to avoid cliches where the
zombie media is concerned because I feel
like that's got to be a struggle what do
you lean into and what do you avoid and
how is The Last of Us tackle those
things it's so challenging yeah
um you know whenever you're dealing with
a specific kind of sub-genre
everything's been done is is how it
feels and so so like the the best thing
to do is be as educated as possible
which means if you're going to write a
zombie show you need to have watched as
many zombie movies and shows as you
possibly can just to understand what's
been done what is the cliche why is it a
cliche
how can you subvert those expectations
and a huge amount of that just comes
from understanding the genre that you're
dealing in in a very real way being a
good viewer I think um
The Last of Us you know the game already
had an enormous level of invention you
know the game is inspired and it was was
very smart about what cliches to embrace
because you're expected yeah to deliver
certain things if you're a zombie story
um and which ones to to invert and and
to surprise with like the game already
laid a lot of that out and I think you
know I think with with with Craig at the
helm of of the show
he's approaching it from a from a
completely different perspective and
adding a new layer of invention on top
of the successful invention that was
already there
um when when we are working
trying to figure out what conventions to
embrace and which ones to try to subvert
is kind of the work of of the writer's
room it's kind of discussions how much
what development is and I would say I
can only really answer this one from the
actor point of view
which is that I've played a lot of
um like you wrote on hush as well right
right on hush but that was like that's a
cliche but we were dealing with the
slasher conventions yeah but you have to
do is
ask yourself over and over again what
would a person do yeah and the thing is
if you watch
five documentaries you'll realize that
people do the most [__] up [__] you
could like nobody responds the way that
you think they will respond
to trauma and so what I like to do what
I like to do in hush and what I like to
do like when we did a vampire show when
we did a ghost story is I would start
with playing the world's worst Choice
like what if you the first time you're
confronted with something you burst out
laughing or like when you think somebody
would stand and fight they turn and run
or what if the solution is right in
front of their face like really trying
to play the opposite and find the human
choice you want to I watch like there's
this documentary called dear Zachary
which I reference a lot in my acting
stuff which is that it goes in places
you would have never thought because
people do things you wouldn't imagine
and so you can't write that you can't
write it and I guess if you're when
you're acting and you pick the most
obvious choice It's usually the one that
you're picking because you've seen other
movies and TV shows do at robinman
because humans do it yeah and so and
this is where they talk about things
like you need your life can't be acting
like you need to go out in the world and
have experiences where you're scared or
when you're shocked or like when we all
went to Halloween Horror Nights I spent
a lot of time just like tracking what I
actually did yeah when I was afraid and
none of it could make it on camera
because I screamed like a small child
and then giggled like it just as it
would have worked in the moment but it
was amazing to me
what people actually did when when
they're startled or scared as opposed to
how we would perform that moment on
camera so it's a lot of trying to strip
away what you've already seen but you
need to have watched it which is why I
think the casting of Melanie lynskey
Linsky was a brilliant choice
that this idea that let's see if we can
find somebody the opposite of what we
thought this character should be yeah
people had some
strong opinions on her Casting
um
and I liked the casting I would have
just liked to have seen a little bit
more of how she got into her position
uh was I think my biggest thing was that
I was like well we understand that like
for Kathleen we understand that your
brother was the leader and then you whip
it through fedra and that happened but
why is everyone afraid of you because I
don't feel like I saw enough of that I
definitely recognize that this beat she
gives in the bedroom that she's very
ruthless but I feel like that's most
people in this world right and it's the
only time actually thus far throughout
the show which I'm loving and I think is
incredible that I've been like I would
have had slightly less before or
slightly more of her I think but I keep
being like what the [__] do I know
compared to people making this show
the the interesting thing is that it
seems to your point earlier about how
this story and how the previous story
directly impact Joel's relationship to
Ellie yeah you know that characters you
otherwise would think conventionally you
need more support for
though I think one of the things that's
successful about the show is that it
really has identified
that relationship as being the only
metric that matters yeah everything else
only matter in how much they change Joel
and Ellie's perspective yeah toward each
other and toward their situation and and
so to that end I think you know because
I I agree with you that the character
in in in most in most conventional shows
would need to either be paired way back
or support it you know more
um and I think like if it's if it's only
about what this teaches Joel and Ellie
then
then great and it's an alternate
universe an alternate way that they
could turn out that is they could have
become that instead either of them
exactly and it you know what what I
thought was interesting to me was when
he finally made it up
um into the house and had to had to pick
up the rifle um
unless I and I could just be projection
but I read Ellie as realizing that he
was
picking off uh the infected that were
close to her and when she when it
occurred to her there's a shot of her
looking up toward the window after one
of them drops and kind of realizing that
Joel's got her back yeah and that's why
she took off running to to try to make
it to Sam that might even be the most
trust the two of them have had up until
that point yes and and that you know and
his frustration
when the clicker makes it into the car
that he couldn't get it you know
um but she still made it out of there
like I that to me I I'd kind of gotten
off of the Kathleen stuff and it's like
okay this is this is about this unspoken
long distance
establishment of not establishment but
the realization that they both had that
this trust existed yeah
um and that to me was what everything
else was just to yeah Etc to do that
like fun center thing yeah a very fun
set dressing you also got to watch
dozens and dozens of very fast infected
really fun pour out of a hole they come
and pop the zit loved it yeah yeah
um and that was awesome so uh but yeah
it's I think they their heart is in the
right place on the show they've
identified what's important
um as far as you know
the the central relationship is all that
matters and all the other relationships
are there to teach us and them about
that reflect on them yeah yeah I think
that's true I think yeah I'm already
excited to re-watch this show which is
weird but I'm already like I can't wait
to finish it and re-watch it because I
think if I do look at every episode with
the lens of what does it mean for Joel
and Ellie which is what I did from
episode three
um this this I'm probably pulling out
way more than they intended or that's me
discrediting them that I keep being like
oh this is an allegory for this and this
means this and it's just fun to like go
through that every week with again I
love the weekly releases with the rest
of the Internet it's been a good time uh
thank you both for joining me today on
that note
um any closing thoughts I guess like
what's your favorite thing about the
show so far it's a fun question to
finish with
uh Bella's performances Ellie I think it
is unique and it's nothing I've ever
seen before from a young actor in terms
of the way she's approaching the
character and the secrets she's keeping
and the choices she's making you don't
see a lot of young actors making those
choices you don't see a lot of adult
actors making those choices and I'm
always surprised by everything she does
I was a fan of hers back in Game of
Thrones and so it's great to see her
continue that Journey
I view the show very much as uh this
incredible Victory lap for two things
that are so commonly maligned
um video games and the horror genre oh
yeah [__] y'all which are underestimated
and routinely kind of dismissed
um and so I just I'm enjoying watching
the total like double fisted middle
finger Victory lap yeah on behalf of
video games and horror
um and having this huge Prestige
audience being just fawning over it that
makes me so happy can I have a second
take and then when you edit my answer
first
no it doesn't work like that I mean I
can yeah if you really want
what's the second take my second take is
you know what I love is I'm viewing the
show as a Victory lap of two uh things
that are generally maligned in this
space which is video games yeah and the
horror community so it's really small I
really just like feel like it's two
middle fingers up [__] you everybody
we're better than you and you know it
wow that's super insightful yeah so I've
never had anyone say that before but
you're gonna dig it like past the end
zone and kind of up the bleachers there
but [__] you literally everybody
great there I saw a really interesting
meme that was like if you
everybody have a snack if you think
everybody hates you take a nap and if
you think everybody hates everybody go
outside so I guess I need a nap that's
very good yeah you should go take a nap
uh thank you both for joining me where
can people find you and what are you up
to at the moment oh uh where can they
find us
um on the social medias yes I'm at uh K
number eight oh wait Kate Siegel
official on Instagram it's where I'm the
most active and I'm on um Twitter uh
Instagram Tick Tock and the Facebook
under uh at Flanagan film all all one
word cool um and we're up to waiting for
our new show yeah uh The Fall of the
House of Usher to be released later this
year there's no date on it yet but we're
we're in post-production we're picture
locked picture locked we're dealing with
visual effects and music effects all the
last minute stuff to just get it done
and we're just so excited for the world
to see that show and hope it's
fractionally as good as the show we're
discussing today yes thank you
see it uh all right thanks for joining
me I'll see you next week everybody
[Music]